you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme the big thaw
how rising temperatures are releasing
millions of tons of carbon
in russia's arctic
parts of china are hit by the heaviest
rain in a thousand years as extreme
weather events continue
to claim lives around the world
and the fossils discovered by a couple
from swindon
which could help teach us about the
environment
million years ago
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world
right now and meet those coming up with
the solutions
permafrost that's permanently frozen
soil lies beneath nearly a quarter of
the northern hemisphere's landmass
and around 65 of russian land
sits on it but temperatures in russia
are heating up
two and a half times faster than the
rest of the world
and as permafrost thaws greenhouse gases
are released
warming the planet further and melting
the permafrost
quicker it's estimated that globally
permafrost holds around 1400 gigatonnes
of carbon
more than is already in the atmosphere
to understand the scale of that
one gigaton is a billion tons of carbon
for people who live in the region the
effects of these dramatic
changes are already being felt diana
magnay reports from chersky
deep in the russian arctic
it is hard to imagine in summer what it
takes to survive minus 55 in winter here
near chersky in the russian arctic
but temperatures here are warming fast
twice to three times the global average
and as they do the permafrost or
permanently frozen soil not
far below ground is thawing causing
massive soil erosion along the arctic
shores and coastlines
and releasing powerful greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere
nikita zimov and his father sergey have
made it their life's work
to raise the alarm over thawing
permafrost when i was a kid
temperature of performance temperature
of ground is ground on average was
minus six centigrade now it's
minus three and even warmer and in the
warm years it's going almost close to
zero
and i think in the next few decades two
three decades at most
i think majority of peripherals here in
arctic will start to degrade
it's already driven a rush in mammoth
tusk ivory
as soil erosion reveals the permafrost's
treasures
that's a big bone of some leg bone of
some
mammoth of a mammoth yeah how do you
know
the size so only mamas could have such
bone
rhinoceros it's a bit different they
also big bones but this one is big
that's quite a
little part of one very big leg bone
but the permafrost also contains
hundreds of billions of tons of carbon
which is slowly being released
that's a pure ice 50 of this sediment
is not carbon it's ice and ice
is melting rapidly ice is mixing with
these sediments
and turn them into mud and all the slide
down
ice is causing ground depressions and
that's something that's
why the sperm frost is dangerous not
only about carbon
carbon which is 40 meter below who cares
it will
sell for millennials and millennials
millennials
ice will make it melt much much faster
to show you what the carbon consists of
we're inside a permafrost cave
they were used a lot for storage here in
the arctic especially by fishermen
these roots are essentially plants that
were frozen
in the soil at the time when the
mammoths were roaming the grasslands
up above but as this stuff thaws this
decomposes
and greenhouse gases are emitted into
the atmosphere
methane and co2 and that warms up the
planet
further the more permafrost degrades the
more buildings will end up looking like
this
the arctic's rusting soviet
infrastructure collapsing
as the ground gives way expected to cost
russia
50 billion pounds a quarter of the
federal budget
by 2050. yes lucia
for a long time sergey zimov was a lone
voice on the dangers of permafrost thor
and the methane he noticed daily
bubbling up from below ground
missing growth so fast last year
it was most fast growths in all history
i feel it's because our permafrost start
to melt
and any point now produced me saying
and we have millions spawned like this
around my house the zemos have a
solution
return the arctic to how it was during
the mammoth era
bring back the millions of animals which
used to roam here
to scrape away and trample down the
insulating layer of snow when they
forage for food
which counterintuitively traps in the
heat
and stops the cold from penetrating
it seems fanciful not least because of
the scale that it would require
yes you know crazy scientists from
russia want to bring what
millions of animals yeah yeah
telemedicine but if you have better
solution
give me one as we travel back a distant
arctic
wildfire turns the sun the color of mars
and lends a haze to the horizon
these fires now raging through siberia
send
more carbon into the atmosphere and warm
the permafrost further
a vicious feedback loop which compounds
the crisis in our climate
dynamic sky news in the russian arctic
in today's other climate news new york
city has registered the worst
air quality in the world as cities in
the united states have been
covered in smoke from wildfires in the
west of the country
washington philadelphia and toronto have
also been affected
with the smoke causing hazy skies and
giving the moon a red tinge
more than 80 wildfires in the western
u.s have burned across nearly 1.3
million
acres of drought-affected land
scientists are warning that extreme
floods in europe could become
much more frequent as a result of global
warming a new study suggests
slow-moving storms could become 14 times
more common
over land by the end of the century
slow-moving storms
cause intense rainfall over a small area
which increases the risk of serious
flooding they can have devastating
impacts as we've seen last week
in germany and belgium
a new study has found men cause more
greenhouse gas emissions
than women that's right scientists
compared single men and women in sweden
and found men are responsible for 16
more emissions
despite spending similar amounts of
money so why might that be
that's right cars the biggest difference
was the amount men spend on petrol
and diesel and prince william is writing
an introduction to a new book
to support his environmental award the
earthshot prize
the book called earthshot how to save
our planet
will highlight the environmental
challenges facing the world
and showcase some of the solutions
already underway
it will also feature contributions from
members of the earthshot prize council
including sir david attenborough there's
been severe flooding in parts of china's
hanan province with a year's worth of
rain
falling in just three days thousands
have been forced to leave their homes
and the public transport system has been
overwhelmed by water
and while floods are common during the
country's rainy season
they are getting more frequent and
intense due to the rapid urbanization
and global warming
our correspondent tom cheshire reports
from beijing
people were making their way back home
after work when the water burst in
it happened so fast that the trains were
still running
inside the carriages commuters were
trapped and what started as an
inconvenience
quickly became the stuff of nightmares
the trains stopped the water rising
up to the next and nothing they could do
but wait
and hope graphic videos on chinese
social media
showed apparently lifeless bodies in the
carriages and on the station platforms
after wildfires in the u.s catastrophic
flooding in europe
it is now china's turn as the climate
crisis bites
hernan province is home to nearly 100
million people
it has been hit by heavy rain since the
weekend
but nearly a year's worth fell in just
one day on the provincial capital of
zhengzhou yesterday
local weather forecasters said it was
the heaviest rainfall
in a thousand years across the city
dozens of vehicles were swept away
a huge rescue operation was launched in
some cases it came down to life and
death moments like this
this woman only just saved from the
deluge
experts have long warned that climate
change would make floods like this
more severe no country pollutes more
than china
but no other country is in a position to
make more of a positive impact on the
climate crisis by reducing emissions
the u.s climate envoy john kerry
yesterday called on china to do more
it should not need that encouragement
the devastation in zhengzhou
is enough proof of the need to act tom
cheshire sky news beijing
now the government would say it has
plenty of policies to try and reduce
emissions
but many argue more will need to be done
to reach net zero by 2050 and slow
global warming
now one of the ideas often mentioned is
a carbon border adjustment
essentially taxing goods that are
imported into the country
that have a high climate impact and that
could be a step closer to being
introduced in the uk
as our economics and data editor ed
conway explains
now a carbon border adjustment has long
been one of those things academics have
talked about but it hasn't seemed very
real but it might be
about to become something that's very
tangible indeed and affect
all of us it's worth just going through
what it is first of all it sounds
complicated but actually it's quite
simple
and if you just look at this line this
white line shows you
uk carbon emissions and look it looks
like they're on the way down doesn't it
but here's the thing
our total carbon footprint the black
line is actually a lot higher
why because of all the carbon intensive
goods we're importing from places like
asia europe and elsewhere so
while domestic producers the white line
have to pay green levees obey green
regulations foreign producers sometimes
don't and that
is where a carbon border adjustment
comes in making them pay the equivalent
costs
when their goods pass the uk border so a
very big deal
i'm here in glasgow with the secretary
of state for trade liz trust i asked her
about whether
the uk was considering a carbon border
adjustment after all the eu
and the us are talking about it in
detail here's what she said about it
it is certainly something that we will
need to look at
in the future if it's the case that
we don't have the net zero targets
agreed
across the board and if it's the case
that we can't get agreement
at the world trade organization but we
do have time to look at this
because the carbon leakage issue isn't
biting at the moment
so the the right approach is to analyze
the evidence and have those multilateral
discussions
at this stage so that was liz truss
signaling that while it's early days
while she hopes for a multilateral
solution it may well be that the uk
might have to introduce some of these
taxes with big consequences
for all of us and finally a couple from
swindon have discovered one of the uk's
largest collections of rare marine
fossils
after stumbling across the site on
google earth
neville and sally hollingworth noticed
the quarry in wiltshire while
researching the geology of the area
online hundreds of samples from 174
to 164 million years ago have now been
collected
which will allow researchers to
understand how our climate has changed
over time well that's all from us for
today
tomorrow more from our moscow
correspondent diana magnay
on the wildfires ripping through siberia
for now
thanks for watching and we'll see you
then
[Music]